et pourrait être réservé entre cugnaux
et beau pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur l'apple c'était
vraiment le laboratoire volant qui
montrait que non seulement on pouvait
s'alimenter au solaire non plus on
pouvait être extrêmement efficients sur
le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il ya un état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère la des stations
ça s'accélère de manière exponentielle
ça veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
ce qui ressemble à une tentative de
mutinerie homélie le président malien
ibrahim boubacar kéita et son premier
ministre vous cissé aurait été arrêté en
fin d'après midi à bamako par des
militaires en révolte affirmation en
tout cas de l'un des chefs de la
mutinerie et mènent le même combat mal
est fait et exprime son plein soutien à
la médiation en cours des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
alexandre loukachenko vient d'annoncer
le déploiement de l'armée le long de la
frontière occidentale de la biélorussie
la situation se tend à la veille d'un
sommet européen extraordinaire sur la
situation à minsk
vladimir poutine condamne toute
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
du pays et 20 ne mettrons en fait son
homologue russe à favoriser l'apaisement
et le dialogue
le verdict très attendu au liban est
tombé 15 ans après l'attentât qui a
coûté la vie à l'ancien premier ministre
rafic hariri est bien une autre personne
l'un des quatre appuis
reste vol a été reconnu coupable les
trois autres ont été acquittés les jeux
jouets ont par ailleurs déclaré qu'il
n'y avait aucune preuve permettant
d'établir un lien direct entre l'attaqué
et la syrie où le mouvement hezbollah
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez situation tendue
et confusion donc au mali qui semble
confronté à l'heure qu'il est à une
mutinerie en pleine crise politique le
président malien ibrahim boubacar keïta
et son premier ministre aurait été
arrêté c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme
l'un des chefs de la mutinerie
il serait dans un blindé en route pour
katyn camp militaire de la banlieue de
bamako là même où la mutinerie a débuté
dans la matinée affirme de son côté une
autre source militaire dans le camp des
mutins
un peu plus tôt le gouvernement malien
avait appelé à un dialogue avec les
militaires pour lever tous les
malentendus des militaires qui ont pris
ce matin le contrôle d'une garnison
proche de bamako suscitant ainsi
l'inquiétude de washington et des pays
voisins
la france elle condamne avec la plus
grande fermeté la tentative de mutinerie
et soutient la médiation de la cedeao la
france a pris connaissance avec
inquiétude de la mutinerie qui s'est
engagé aujourd'hui à cathy au mali la
france réaffirme avec force ont plein
attachement à la souveraineté et à la
démocratie malienne
les autorités françaises au plus haut
niveau reste très attentive à
l'évolution de la situation au mali la
cedeao rappelle sa ferme opposition à
tout changement politique anti
constitutionnelle et invite les
militaires à demeurer dans une posture
républicaine
en tout état de cause elle condamne
vigoureusement la tentative en cours et
prendra toutes les mesures et actions
nécessaires à la restauration de l'ordre
constitutionnel et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct par téléphone avec izia
cas tamboura journaliste directeur du
journal le soft bonsoir il ya quatre ans
voire merci d'être avec nous en direct
donc du mali
le chef de la mutinerie affirme
l'arrestation du président queille
taxons premier ministre à ce que c'est
une information qui vous paraît crédible
est ce que vous disposez d'autres
informations
bonsoir à tous les téléspectateurs de
l'arche de france je vous confirme que
le fait que le président soit reconduite
de sa de son domicile à de bamako à
cathy l'information qui a été vérifiée
devrait vite elle a affirmé aux
manifestants qui se trouvaient au
monument de l'indépendance de bamako
mais évidemment est le véhicule idéal
dans lequel il était connu a été
évidemment conduit manu militari avec le
club de véhicules du pénis donc tout un
cocktail qui a été conduit avec rodez
vannes avec des militaires et il ya
aussi des véhicules des militaires donc
cette information est crédible
ça veut dire il n'ya quand on voit
clairement que ce soir on peut parler de
tentative de mutinerie
il faut que mutinerie parce que les
soldats qui se sont mutinés et ils ont
exprimé leur colère mais tout en ne
disant pas jusque là
pourquoi ils se sont mutinés et 7 ans du
régime libéral m'ont affirmé que les
soldats se sont mutinés parce que il ya
une alerte
c'est aussi ce qui fait des rencontres
qui se sont révoltés contre des
officiers supérieurs mais n'a pourquoi
la question reste posée
mais à l'ère vous et vous pendre c'est
une mutinerie et l'est qui s'étire
inexorablement ils ne savent eux dire
clairement que l'on peut craindre à un
coup d'état potentiel ce soit évidemment
on peut craindre un coup d'état ce soir
parce que on vient de me dire aussi que
les mythes et les soldats qui ont
conduit le président à katyn au réal à
l'utile à part lui demander de
démissionner ménahès que le président
avait accepté de démissionner je pense
que c'est un président qui est qui qui a
dans la tête
donc on ne peut pas dire que le
président avait accepté avant qu'on ne
voie mais il est très en forme à son qg
l'objectif
avoir amené un cas qui est pour lui
demander de démissionner mais ensuite
tout de la situation
à quoi peut-on s'attendre issiaka
tamboura ce soir ce que vous l'avez dit
voilà que le président en tête qu'il a
été élu démocratiquement ne sais pas
quelle va être sa réponse on imagine
qu'il va pas forcément accepter aussi
facilement mais tout de même à quoi
peut-on s'attendre est ce que on
pourrait aller vers une transition ou le
transfert d'un pouvoir au civil où ça
paraît un petit peu prématuré pour le
dire ce soir je n'ai pas prématuré
puisque les choses sont allées très vite
madame et ce soir on pourrait dès mon
coin de vie avec la situation qu'il est
suivi de bout en bout on pouvait
s'attendre à un coup d'état qui va être
annoncé
mais n'a d'autre part est ce que ça sera
une transition ménagers parce que ça
doit être dans ses cadres au cas où
s'est confirmée au cas où c'est la
volonté des milieux et au cas où et riza
accepte se diriger vers une transition
mais je crois que traditionnellement les
traditions au mali comme le stipule la
constitution c'est le président de
l'assemblée qui doit conduire la
transition pour l'intérêt de 40 41 jours
délai au cours duquel il doit pouvoir
aux élections présidentielles mais à
l'aller où je vous parle la situation du
territoire malien qui occupé à plus d'un
titre
il est impossible de revendre des
élections et l'autre point qui est
compliqué c'est le fait que les
manifestants aussi on y rencontre le
président de l'assemblée qui lui
reprochent d'avoir été mal élu
donc c'est très difficile de dire que
c'est le créa la table et qui
éventuellement pourraient conduire la
tranche donc là c'est là la pomme c'est
le problème aujourd'hui qui va diriger
une éventuelle transition puisque que
les militaires et toul avec le même
président aujourd'hui qui divise le pays
encore je crois que la situation est
mais ça ne va pas s'arranger à l'heure
actuelle
effectivement les et on rappelle à cet
événement arrive après plusieurs mois de
manifestations anti-gouvernementales
appelant à la démission du président il
ya beaucoup de tension
au mali est ce que d'une certaine
manière il fallait crever l'abcès
selon vous moi je pense que le président
a redit au moins c'est accepter comme
les halles avec beaucoup de personnes
l'avaient dit là s'il ya ou il avait dit
au moins de mettre en place un intrus
ministre consensuel
ça c'était vraiment la seule à la moins
la moitié est mais le président avait
décidé de garder sont revenus comme le
stipule la constitution
je crois que on aurait dû passer par le
dialogue mais un coup d'état c'est
regrettable on va reculer de manu a
reculé on n'est pas sortis on n'est pas
sorti des difficultés du coup d'état de
mars 2012 encore on retombe dans un
hôpital un coup dans un autre coup
d'état militaire mais c'est malheureux
pour notre pays la france condamne ce
soir la cedeao aussi quelle est leur
marge de manoeuvre
les remarques de manoeuvre et connie ils
vont condamner le coup d'état au cas où
sur le court et a éventuellement ils
vont condamner les poulets l'action est
suspendue le mali évidemment et c'est ce
qui faisait qui faisaient les frontières
c'est sûr que le mythe est venu fermer
leurs frontières au cas où le coup de
grâce est conscient mais je suis sûr
qu'il a passé la main les etats unis ont
réagi également la cedeao a dit la porte
je crois que cette communauté
internationale est resté intransigeant
sur le fait que le président est il
écrit qu'un président démocratiquement
élu et un sens mais ça doit
anticonceptionnelle est à dire expert
constitutionnel est inacceptable
donc c'est malika s'attendre dans le dos
qui suivent à des sanctions de la
communauté internationale
on sait qu'il ya cette passion serval
puis barkan a lancé par la france serait
ce que finalement
la france et la cedeao ont des marges de
manoeuvre vraiment élevé puisque d'une
certaine manière cette instabilité
montre une forme d'impuissance de ces
opérations françaises dans ses homélies
bien sûr ça montre cette action montre
la puissance des opérations étrangères
roumanie il faut le dire puisque dès
2013 et 2013 où la française emmie
intervenir avec le prêt sans sel valdano
sur madame de la sécurité mais la fête
qui s'est dégradée et bien sur le départ
les choses avaient commencé à avancer et
le groupe diniz avait commencé à fuir
les ballets roses et vous tente il y à t
et la zone de la raison de ce coup c'est
à dire les extrémités de bamako le vix
qui cultivent bamako ce sont ses villes
ses mains qui aujourd'hui qui sont aussi
mis la ville donc c'est grave ne s'est
pas pour autant ses portes jusqu'à
présent et la situation n'a fait que se
dégrader
c'est toute la situation sécuritaire ce
qui a fait que les avis des
mécontentements au niveau des dépenses
sociales et c'est ce qui a conduit à
cette situation malheureuse et l'autre
merci beaucoup il n'y a qu'un tambour à
jour des listes un directeur du journal
le sauf en direct donc de bamako au mali
où on l'aura compris c'est une situation
de confusion avec vous le disiez non pas
une tentative de mutinerie mais une
mutinerie tout court évidemment nous
reviendrons sur ces événements dans nos
prochaines éditions merci en tout cas à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur rt france
alors que la contestation populaire se
poursuit en biélorussie le pays a
déployé des unités de combat de l'armée
sur les frontières occidentales et les
amener à se préparer au combat
déclarations d'alexandre loukachenko à
la veille d'un sommet européen
historique où il sera question la
situation dans son pays
écoutez le président biélorusse choc
nous au tchad
je tiens à le souligner une fois de plus
il est très regrettable que nous ayons
dû employer certaines unités
surtout celle des forces d'opérations
spéciales pour rétablir l'ordre dans
notre pays
il s'agit d'une partie de notre
population
ce n'est pas qu'ils ne comprennent pas
ils le font délibérément donc compte
tenu de cette composante extérieure
comme le disent les militaires nous
sommes obligés d'agir de manière
adéquate
je vous demande de le garder à l'esprit
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas uniquement
des problèmes à l'intérieur mais aussi
ceux qui proviennent de l'extérieur et
nous voyons clairement que ce sont des
activités tout à fait coordonnées mais
il ne s'agit même pas encore du point
culminant la situation évoluera en
conséquence et nous savons déjà
dans quelle direction ou dans un présent
l'analyse du président du centre de
recherches scientifiques de minsk pour
la première fois la biélorussie est unie
et la jada est assez simple lukashenko
doit partir les tortionnaires doivent
être condamnées et les prisonniers
politiques doivent être libérés mais
loukachenko quand il a proposé cette
constitution c'est comme tout projet de
réforme de la loi
commençons pas la bureaucratie et lui
c'est le maître de la bureaucratie donc
il est probable que l'opposition
biélorusse n'accepte pas cela je ne
pense pas que des sanctions économiques
sur les principaux produits biélorusse
tels que les engrais les produits
pétroliers les métaux soit imposé je
pense que le kremlin est aussi
désemparés ne sait pas quoi faire
prendre aujourd'hui le parti de
loukachenko et lui apporter son soutien
signifie s'opposer à 99% de la
population biélorusse ce n'est pas la
meilleure stratégie pour avoir de bonnes
relations avec un pays limitrophe et
pour forger une alliance stratégique y
avoir des valeurs communes soit au sein
de l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie soit au sein de l'union
économique eurasiatique
le tribunal spécial pour le liban a donc
rendu son verdict quinze ans après la
mort du premier ministre rafic hariri et
de 21 autres personnes
un seul des quatre accusés salim ayyash
membres du hezbollah étaient jugés
coupables les trois autres ont été
acquittés saad hariri son fils dit
accepter cette décision le tribunal a
statué et au nom de la famille de
l'ancien premier ministre rafic hariri
et au nom des familles des martyrs et
victimes
nous acceptons la décision du tribunal
l'assassinât de rafic hariri a été en
2005 un véritable onde de choc au liban
retour en images sur ce feuilleton
politico judiciaire qui a rythmé la vie
politique libanaise
[Musique]
plus
oh
le liban qui doit faire face à une
hausse des cas de kovy 19 à tel point qu
un recond finement vient d'être annoncée
leur confinement total qui exclut les
quartiers sinistrés par l'explosion du 4
août au port de beyrouth entrera en
vigueur à partir de vendredi jusqu'au 7
septembre un nouveau record quotidien de
contamination atteint été atteint avec
456 nouveaux malades plus de 9300 cas
depuis le début de l'épidémie les
hôpitaux sont saturés
nous sommes au bord du gouffre a déclaré
hier le ministre démissionnaire de la
santé quatre hôpitaux de la capitale qui
accueillait des quatre kobe 19 avaient
été mis hors service après le drame du 4
août la crise ducobu 19 en france
présent le port du masque sera
systématisé dans les entreprises d'ici
la fin du mois d'août une annonce de la
ministre du travail après une réunion
avec les partenaires sociaux
le gouvernement précise suivent les
préconisations le haut conseil de la
santé publique cela concerne tous les
espaces de travail clos et partager
comme les salles de réunion couloir
vestiaires et open space et autres
moyens de lutte contre le virus les
tests l'exécutif mis sur une politique
de test gratuit à grande échelle
problème les laboratoires sont saturés
parfois fermé en ce mois d'août
une plateforme téléphonique a donc été
mise en place pour faciliter la prise en
charge en région parisienne côté
chiffres le nombre de nouveaux cas
s'élève hier à près de 500 une baisse
significative après un week-end de forte
hausse mais pas de quoi rassurer pour
autant face à la crise sanitaire le chef
de l'état a appelé à la vigilance et à
l'unité
il faut dire que l'inquiétude d'une
seconde vague est bien réelle les
hôpitaux ils sont ils préparés non pour
stéphen aiguilles et secrétaire général
du collectif inter mme block écoutez si
certaines problèmes ont été réglés à
savoir que des respirateurs ont été
achetés on a toujours un problème de de
fourniture de protection individuelle
donc là maintenant
que de mankono baise toujours de masse
que les ffp2 faut savoir qu'ils sont
toujours périmés ce qu'on a on a des
masques périmés de 2008 par exemple
qu'est ce qu'on y voit là c'est partout
pareil que ses intentions qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'approvisionner qu' il
faut faire attention quand on doit
vraiment être vigilent sur ce qu'on
consomme les blues stérile sans stop
très tendu les gosses terry c'est pareil
et nous au blog c'est notre outil de
travail donc forcément si on en a plus
on m'a donné ça va être très
problématique nous on pourra pas se
protéger avec des sacs poubelles pour
opérer les gens quoi c'est pas possible
donc on se demande où est la préparation
encore une fois edouard snowden
bénéficiera-t-il de la grâce
présidentielle de donald trump accusé de
trahison aux états unis mais exilé en
russie où il bénéficie de l'asile
politique
le lanceur d alerte cesse de clamer son
innocence retour sur cette affaire avec
des scènes chimie il était l'homme à
battre un traître dans la bouche même de
donald trump et pourtant edouard snowdon
pourrait être gracié par le président
américain exilé en russie depuis 2013
il avait dénoncé la même année la
surveillance massive des communications
et d'internet aux etats-unis et dans
plusieurs autres pays du monde
l'informaticien américains de la nasa
avait découvert par hasard un document
secret point de départ de son enquête
une enquête qui va le conduire le 6 juin
2013 a contacté deux personnes le rat
poitras documentaliste et glenn green
world journaliste au guardian
objectif pour lui révéler au grand jour
ce scandale d'état lié à l'aîné sa mise
sur écoute de nombreux dirigeants
étrangers dont d'anciens présidents
français tels que nicolas sarkozy
collecte de données relatives à des
citoyens américains surveillance de
câbles sous marins de télécommunications
intercontinental surveillance
d'institutions internationales comme le
conseil européen à bruxelles ou encore
le siège des nations unies le jeune
analyste met à l'heure en gare de monde
contre des programmes de surveillance en
ligne baptisé prisme ou encore x qui est
score il devient alors un ennemi d'état
inculpé au pénal par la justice
américaine pour espionnage et vols de
secrets d'état
et encore même jusqu'à 30 ans de prison
alors qu'il comptait demander l'asile
à la république d'équateur il est bloqué
le 23 juin 2013 à l'aéroport de moscou
pour un problème de passeport
il passera un mois avant de demander
l'asile à la russie moscou et répondra
favorablement depuis la justice
américaine ne cesse de réclamer son
extradition en 2013 en pleine campagne
présidentielle
donald trump n'a pas hésité à qualifier
l'informaticien de traîtres en
promettant s'il était élu de le traité
durement obamacare est un désastre et
snowdon est un espion qui devrait être
exécutée
mais s'il pouvait révéler les archives
d'obama je pourrais devenir un grand fan
snow donnait un traître est une honte ne
vous y trompez pas il n'est pas un héros
en fait c'est un lâche qui devrait
revenir et faire face à la justice
mais le 13 août dernier lors d'une
interview donnée depuis le bureau ovale
au new york post
les journalistes américains assiste à
une véritable volte-face
il y a beaucoup de gens qui pensent
qu'il n'est pas traitée équitablement je
veux dire j'entends ça une intervention
du président américain qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue le principal intéressé
n'a d'ailleurs pas tardé à réagir sur
twitter
la dernière fois que nous avons entendu
une maison blanche envisager une grasse
c'était en 2016
lorsque le même procureur général qui
m'a une fois inculpé a admis que dans
l'ensemble mon travail pour dénoncer le
système inconstitutionnel de
surveillance de masse de l'année ça
avait été un service public
alors pourquoi un tel coup théâtre
doit-on voir dans le rétro pédalage de
donald trump un lien avec la course à la
maison blanche ou une simple pique
adressée aux démocrates le 15 août
dernier
non son golf de bge minster dans le
new-jersey le président américain
surprend de nouveau les journalistes en
laissant entendre qu'il pourrait
envisager une grâce beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'il devrait être traité
différemment et d'autres gens pensent
qu'il a fait des choses très mauvaise je
vais y jeter un oeil très sérieusement
l'avocat de snowdon estime lui que la
grâce est inappropriée car son client
n'a commis aucun crime
il souligne même néanmoins une avancée
dans le dossier
je crois que si trump a abordé ce sujet
c'est qu'il partage les principes et les
idéaux de droits et de libertés des
citoyens que snowdon prêche le fait même
que trump est dit cela montre qu'il n'y
ait pas un différend dont je pense qu'il
va s'occuper de la situation
un espoir pour certains une stratégie de
campagne pour d'autres quoi qu'il en
soit si donald trump venait à lui
accorder la grâce edward snowdon
deviendrait le premier lanceur dallaire
être graciée dans le cadre d'un scandale
d'état
le soudan l'egypte et l'ethiopie se sont
réunis aujourd'hui pour résoudre le
conflit du méga barrages construits par
addis abeba sur le nil bleu
les ministres des trois pays ont fondu
de désigner des experts afin d'effacer
leurs divergences des négociations se
poursuivront demain
khartoum et le caire réclame des
garanties en terme d'approvisionnement
en eau une ressource capitale alors que
les premiers effets du réchauffement
climatique pourraient se faire ressentir
plus de détails avec un thé au combat
c'est un projet que n'aurait pas renié
les pharaons pourtant le méga barrages
construits en ethiopie sur le nil bleu
principal affluent du nil suscite
l'inquiétude de l'egypte et du soudan
les deux pays situés en aval du fleuve
craignent de voir leur approvisionnement
en eau soumis au bon vouloir d'addis
abeba une question vitale puisque le nil
représente par exemple 80 17% de
l'approvisionnement en eau potable de
l'egypte
objectif des deux pays impactés par ce
projet entamé en 2011
obtenir un accord contraignant sur la
gestion du barrage les deux parties ont
discuté du projet de barrage éthiopien
renaissance et il a été souligné qu'il
est nécessaire de négocier un accord
contraignant sur le remplissage et
l'exploitation du barrage d'une manière
qui préserve les droits et les intérêts
des trois pays neuf des propositions
pour l'instant refusée par l'ethiopie le
grand barrage pour la renaissance c'est
son nom est une fierté nationale dans un
pays
et par les divisions ethniques et les
fractures politiques
ce colosse de béton de 145 mètres de
haut doit devenir la plus grande
installation hydroélectrique d'afrique
et fournir de l'électricité à tous ses
habitants
alors que près de la moitié en sont
privés aujourd'hui si les négociations
patinent
les trois partis reste pourtant
optimiste récemment l'ethiopie a même
fait quelques concessions
les divergences sur les aspects
techniques se sont atténuées au cours de
la tripartie l'ethiopie pour remplir le
barrage en trois ans grâce à une saison
des pluies de cette ampleur il est très
facile pour l'ethiopie de le remplir
instantanément mais compte tenu du
véritable intérêt de l'ethiopie à
répondre aux préoccupations des pays en
aval à savoir l'egypte et le soudan
nous sommes prêts à prolonger le
remplissage de 4 à 7 ans chapeauté par
l'union africaine les négociations
s'annoncent difficiles
l'ethiopie vient d'annoncer avoir
atteint un niveau de remplissage
suffisant pour faire fonctionner les
premières turbines du barrage
un passage en force qui risque de
froisser davantage ses voisins et
compter à présent l'analyse de marc
lavergne directeur de recherche au cnrs
c'est un problème technique qui devait
être gêné j'ai eu dirigé réglée par des
techniciens avec des diplomates bien sûr
mais qui na qui doit aboutir à ce que
l'intérêt général préval puisque ces
trois pays seront toujours riverains et
voisins et sont condamnés à travailler
ensemble
aucune guerre aucune crise aucun bras de
fer ne plus régler ce problème dans
l'intérêt général des trois pays qui
sont aussi le développement de
l'ethiopie
c'est la production d'électricité qui va
profiter à toute la région
donc les gîtes elle se bat un petit peu
à mes yeux le dos au mur avec une sorte
de mauvais procès et si maintenant on
entre dol des négociations plus longue
qui permettent de mettre sur pied un
accord durable équitable
et bien c'est très bien
mais le barrage de toutes façons de va
se faire va se remplir va produire de
l'électricité que les pays d'aval le
veuille ou non c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point dans 30
[Musique]